starting pitcher for the cubs
ally and this will be his fourth start
he's made a couple of
relief appearances as well swing and a
miss on the change
kipnis has a slab of tape
on his glove and says gold glove that
glove looks pretty worn in
positive affirmation it's not rizzo's we
know that
i don't know if kipnis has his own first
baseman's mitt
or borrowed from somebody else
backdoor breaking ball strike three
called beautiful pitch by
alzali he fans grand all chris bryant
belted a grand slam in last night's game
let's see if he can get a little rally
started in the second against reynaldo
lopez and he drives one in the air deep
left field
it's got a chance it's gone
long gone man he just about hit
the statue out there well how good is
that
cub fans to see chris bryant do it not
just last night but step up there today
and deliver yet another one
don't take the chains off of chris
bryant
and he is jacked up bodhi playing second
base
all right drive well hit back on an
angle he is at the barrier
gone three nothing david bodie with
number seven
and that'll get him off the interstate
he was at 198 before that swing
pointing out towards the cubs bullpen uh
somebody must have said you're going to
go deep today
mr boaty bases are loaded and now the
cubs are looking at a potential
huge inning purple line drive base it
right center field
this is gonna drive in one this is gonna
drive in two
and hamilton races to third two run
single cameron maven
cubs lead five to nothing a short and
disappointing day for ronaldo
he will depart carlos rodon will come
into this
still only one out and they're at the
corners as maven
takes off throw to the plate safe
hamilton got in so maven just took off
for a second
and they threw down and when that
happened hamilton
scampered home at six to nothing yeah
that's what
billy hamilton brings to the table it's
close
stay safe runners at first and second
one away
six nothing cubs in the second
as alzolai strikes out mazara he's got
four strikeouts here in the early game
lined off the glove of alzheimer goes
right to the second baseman
david bodie to end the inning
picked by bryant he'll spin throw and
keptness stayed on the bag he's out it's
a nice play by kb and a nice play by
kipnis
as that's the first play he's had to
stretch out and he's hearing it
is he put the ball in his pocket that's
the first play i've had to make in first
base
i'll just keep this baseball
[Applause]
henderson went and he strikes out
breaking ball strike three called alzali
strikes out moncada
this to shortstop tim flags it down off
the spin
he got here nice play well that was an
outstanding play ranging up the middle
he's deep in the outfield and he guns
down horner
hamilton on the right side and he drives
one out into deep left center and it's
gone billy hamilton getting in on the
act
cubs have hit three today i'm telling me
to hit the ball in the ground and use my
speed
advert also is carrying over what he did
in his
last outing that's number eight
for al's ally so that is a new career
high
and strikeouts for advert two outs the
base is empty adam engel tries one of
the air to right center field
backing on ms maven that ball is going
to be gone
opposite field home run off the bat of
adam engel
it just feels good for the white sox to
show up and at least
get something on the board bryant is one
for three as he waits for jimmy
cordero broken bad roller knocked down
by the pitcher
and he'll throw to first and it gets
away
schwarber rounding third he's heading
home he's gonna score
cubs lead nine to one
that's a base hit 10-1 as bryant will
score
in a blowout game gio gonzalez comes on
to get some outs
and geo might have hurt himself yeah
he's walking off the mountain now
they're going to go check on him
throws a good hook but if anything to me
that looks like an elbow issue
you're going to have to come out of the
ball game goes from bad to worse
for the white sox this should be fun 21
year old
6'4 lefty braylon marquez making his
major league debut
having never pitched above a ball
ground ball a run will score
as horner throws out the batter
randall 10-2 now swing and a miss
on 99. jose abreu raylan
marquez's first strikeout victim
robert right center field this one gets
down louise has his second hit today
and the sox make it 10-3
here comes another run and carnacion
scores robert to second
and it's ten to four it's going to be an
ugly line here
for marquez but you see the stuff
that's at base hit they're gonna score
again as the socks are not done just yet
it's ten to five a four run eighth
inning not the best of
big league debuts for braylon marquez
but better days ahead young man
adam to third that's a diving stop for
bryant throw to first not in time in
field single
ten to six suddenly the sox rev the
engine again
here in the eighth the sox with a
comeback here
could still win the central
rondelle drills it right field ten to
eight here come the socks
come on home run number eight he's
driven in three today
here comes chafin to try to close it out
and it's a safe spot
there it is strike three cubs win
cubs win they take two of three against
the white sox